hide the pain breathe through it Lions
breath hi everyone I'm hide the pain
Herald I've been hiding the pain for 34
years now and that has led to this
[Music]
okay let's hide the pain coming on to
our hands and knees and then once you
get there start moving through your cat
pouch
lift your chest release the pain from
here let's take a big twist reaching
that left arm up oh hey fancy seeing you
down here breathe through the pain and
it float your right leg upwards flutter
the lips and then bone by bone roll up
through your spine see ya hide the pain
let's reach our arms high over ahead now
bringing the palms together in prayer
and then bow down finding your fold
crawl forward hover down chaturanga lift
into your backbend big smile and then
send your hips high
downward dog float your left leg upwards
step your foot between your hands and
then rise up to your high lunge
repeat after me inhaling release the
pain sitting low for our goddess oh yeah
baby hide the pain and then bring your
hands to me in front of your chest take
a big inhale reach your arms up and then
cactus your arms lion's breath and then
let's sit low coming into our yoga
school bring your right hand down in
front of your right foot reach your left
arm upwards and it slowly rise up to
standing maybe straighten that right leg
hide the pain breathe through it and
[Music]
remember kids as butter once said one
can be in pain but once you don't
receive any game namaste
you